[Music]
today's question comes from james in
alabama james writes i'm in an
embarrassing situation i'm 36 years old
and i'm a hoarder
i have over
invested into video games comics and
toys
this is consuming the home that my
mother and i live in which is making her
unhappy
i have about fifteen thousand dollars in
debt and earn about thirty five grand a
year i'm really starting to wake up
after watching your show and i've been
thinking about selling 99 of my stuff
and living a simpler life
i just feel lost in the process and i
have trouble letting things go how can i
change my mindset about these things
i've collected this is tough
um
dave this is one of those challenges
that people start trying to solve the
the immediate pros the immediate problem
right in front of them
and you can do that but something that
is
going on in james life i'm going to
guess is deep seated that he needs to go
do some hard work he's 36 still living
at home he's packed up stuff he's he's
running and hiding this is a person
who's very anxious
um and he's probably got some childhood
trauma that he's dealing with so when i
feel people get in this situation i just
can't break through i can't break i
can't break this person needs to go sit
down and she's awesome boarding is the
symptom not the problem correct right it
is usually
um a response almost always is actually
some sort of anxiousness or trauma
response yeah i've had some stuff go on
and i just start collecting and
collecting and collecting and i don't
want to let go because i might need it
it's preparatory and all of a sudden you
look up and you can't move in your home
right
and this guy's distinguished for me
because i i've got this friend
who might be a little bit ocd and uh
he's got collections of things i have a
collection of water skis i have a
collection of
wine i have a collection of guns i have
a collection of whatever right
and um those things are things i got
drawn into
and usually the community around them
um and that they represent and or the
memory or something um and so i just
enjoyed the process and they and they
sometimes not all of them but some
things run their course like i i used to
buy a lot more guns than i buy now yeah
but i've kind of got the i'm kind of
full so i haven't bought in a bunch of i
don't buy
anywhere near the volume i used to uh so
i kind of ran its course so to speak but
that's what's the difference in a
collector and a hoarder
uh i would suggest a collector or
somebody like you said that has a good
community this is something you do this
is something you enjoy
that thing that you're buying doesn't
own you right okay and so i get a
paycheck
i can't not go buy this thing
it's an addiction
and if i said if if sharon came to you
and said we have to sell some of these
guns your initial response is
i can't do that oh actually not an
intellectual argument not a not a well
why would we do that it's i can't part
with this and so you can look at
somebody's house who's a hoarder and say
throw it away you're asking them to peel
back layers of security that they've
walls that they've built literally okay
and so
this starts with man there's even even a
difference between someone who's a very
aggressive um
because i can remember like times i've
been in a zone like i i got on a hunt
for that thing yeah because to complete
the collection you're a hunter yeah
and i enjoyed that part of it but that's
different than i can't live without it
spiritually and you also did it
differently when you had resources and
finances and when you didn't oh yeah
yeah it's it's a very very small
percentage of the world that's your net
worth right it's not like you missed
okay i'm feeling better because i was
kind of worried
well if you ever need to unload some of
your wine or guns or bourbon holler at
me and i know a guy but
so james here's the thing um i want you
to reach out to a friend
reach out to a pastor in your community
that you trust a counselor reach out to
somebody and say
i'm ready to get well and this is gonna
be hard and you're gonna have some stuff
you have to deal with you're gonna have
to go back and revisit some stuff that's
going on in your life but the fact that
you're ready is so good man it's hard to
get people here it feels like if you if
he were to come up under this
and start getting well the result would
be the release of it it can be that you
just started it wouldn't be it wouldn't
be as much of a tearing right it feels
like right now there'd be a
ripping sound a tearing sound and when
that happens is what happens you'll find
somewhere else to plug this so you can
hire a crew to come clean your house out
throw everything away and that addiction
will just jump to something else yeah
right yeah the problem is still is still
under there somewhere that's right but
good for you james yeah and you know
here's the other thing i've bought real
estate from people that were hoarders
yes and um
tremendous problem
uh
even getting inside to see the house on
the inside the shame yeah from our true
hoarders really dealing with
psychological issues
the shame around it is unbelievable you
just pull called something that's
important a lot of people think i'm a
hoarder
and then you go to somebody's home who's
a true hoarder and you go oh i'm not
trash it's completely i mean stuff
smells like the ceiling smells bad
always smells bad it's always nasty it's
uh it's animals it's different oh it's
gross it's different so gross yeah yeah
i bought houses like that and we had to
you know entire dumpsters outside after
the you know maybe even the hoarder had
passed away and we bought it from the
estate and gone in and cleaned it out
it's amazing and it's mind-blowing when
you go in there so anytime you're about
identity change it starts with looking
in the mirror and saying i'm worth more
than this and let's start the healing
there but good for you james i'm proud
of you brother yeah very good stuff very
good good man yeah that's very smart to
recognize that and here's the other
thing he did really good that i think is
a sign for his healing is he put numbers
around this and he started recognizing
they were out of balance because he put
him in the email he did two things that
were i make 35 i got 50
and uh and i owe 15. yep i heard the
three numbers and i want to sell 99 of
this stuff
yeah so he did two things he put numbers
around it and he took full
responsibility yeah he didn't say i have
this because of the he said yeah this is
on me and i gotta make some changes
where do i start yeah and this starts
with saying stuff out loud to somebody
else but still once he even though he's
that that's a really good first line
rung on the ladder he's still got to get
up under it
otherwise it's going to just his parts
of his heart are going to leave that's
he needs to he needs to detach from the
heart before the stuff leaves that's
right that's exactly right that's a
great way to put that
wow this isn't a matter of just throwing
stuff away you know in america we've all
got just about everybody's got stuff
it's of some kind i get that i get i'll
be happy if i could just get that card
i'll be happy if i could buy millions
and billions of dollars that we have in
storage was it billions
of storage space yeah i don't know it's
ridiculous yeah yeah we spend more on
storing stuff than most countries gdp
bonkers stuff that we don't use yeah
we're the only country in the world that
when someone moves they have a box
labeled seldom used kitchen items
it's like yeah i've gotta
i i'll be happy when
i'll be happy i get that thing from
ronco that's the big difference the two
sets of knives can you be happy without
that gun could you be happy without that
car would it be cool and nice of course
it would
will i still be worth being loved if i
don't have that yeah i quit buying cars
for other people a long time ago that's
that's that's another thing's going
broke i still got really nice cars again
i got really nice cars but they're for
me i love that just because i like
driving it and i don't really care
whether you like it or not because i
like it yeah that's a whole different
thing than i used to do in my 20s whole
different thing